[Music]
and what I've come to understand is that
there are these incredible pictures that
contain all the information of a set of
equations that are related to string
theory and it's even more bizarre than
that because when you then try to
understand these pictures you find out
that buried in them are computer codes
just like the type that you find in the
browser when you go surf the web you say
your attempt to understand the
fundamental operations of nature leads
you to a set of equations that are
indistinguishable from the equations
that drive search engines and browsers
and our computers that is the red boom
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Don sake and super pumped
to be talking about simulation theory we
have Ryan dice bosons and joining us on
the show hello hello brother thank you
so much for coming on thank you for
having me very grateful very blessed
we're finally landing this episode
together after doing a lot of circling
around each other very pumped to be
talking about simulation theory with you
for those who don't know Ryan's
background Ryan has spent 15 years in
doing visual effects computer-generated
imagery he's done a lot of simulation to
screen work at Lucas arts at Sony and
other cup companies he's a partner at
Karis Capital Management right now he's
also strategic advisor at versus which
is architecting the spatial web he is
doing lots of work in the emerging tech
space so this is the perfect topic for
us and let's dive into this from what we
just listened to we just listen to this
beautiful dialogue about the codified
universe the codified world and it's the
20th anniversary of the matrix in it's
crazy that how well that Illustrated
what we're about to talk about
launched us into this yeah I mean it's a
beautiful appropriate time to honor that
legacy that the Wachowski were so aptly
able to transmit very inspired by philip
k dick and a whole kind of lineage of
gnostic tradition behind that kind of
wrapped into this tech gnosis frame that
we have now so it's it's Eric Davis but
yeah it's it's a it's a paradigm shift
it's a really amazing opportunity I
think to to evolve to integrate and
evolve our model of reality and a plea
simulation on the simulation here and
we're working with versus on the
simulation within the simulation so
there's a bit of this like recursive
fractal stuff I'm sure we'll get into
yes but yeah the Wachowskis they they
throughout the narrative frame right
alongside Wilbur ken wilber working with
integral theory on a kind of
philosophical transpersonal framework
and yeah it's it's an incredible time to
honor this incredible transition period
the opportunity coming through this this
trans rational phase of recognizing the
simulation nature of this game in taking
us all the way back on a big history
perspective we have all these like
archaic means a first discovering
language and art and communication in
these initial inventions and then we
have this this crazy you know relate the
period of religion and spirituality and
that type of growth a lot of the self
work process the inward process and now
this most recent technological explosion
that's occurred that has taken us into
the digital world which is all on like
the objective science and thank you so
now we're kind of merging you know
that's one of the other things about
this this trans rational as you
described it teach us about this this
trans rational of the objective and the
subjective that touches a little bit on
Wilbur's framework with integral theory
and it's it's kind of this synthesizing
system and what he what he
orab in dough was another in that
lineage of using this kind of a
framework to to map an inclusive kind of
holistic mapping of or cartography of
reality through like a philosophical
framework so many of our even you know
most incredibly brilliant philosophers
and and and thinkers have contributed
very powerful types of ideology or ways
of thinking but they've been kind of
partial as much as they've been like
true and and there's been great power
and certain kinds of thinkers
they've been partial they haven't really
mapped the the whole of actuality as as
Wilbert kind of was carrying a thread
from its just giving me right now but a
lot of people say that it's very elusive
the when you're trying to you're trying
to explain the code of all that is it's
a very elusive thing to try and be able
sure are you sure and and and yet we're
also moving into this period where it is
automating itself and we can get into
that more as well but what well Wilbur
was doing when you're talking about like
the Cartesian dualism the interior the
exterior there being these times that
we're looking at through spiral dynamics
as kind of pre rational mapping of the
interior of consciousness in a way and
then you could look at the from kind of
the modern and postmodern phases as this
this process of mapping the exterior the
objective world the subject object
dualism that sort of things so primary
dualism with a cart will burgers kind of
expanded that into pluralistic systems
so you have the the left side is the
interior the subjective side the right
side is the exterior objective side and
the bottom quadrants so there's you know
singular up above so upper left is
interior singular the eye and then upper
right is like the outer you could say
like the body in that
you know which would be the it like my
body is a thing and then below those two
quadrants you would you would say the
lower left is like the inner subjective
like the we the collective consciousness
unconsciousness that we want to look at
that and then the outer lower right is
the the system's right so the kind of
pleural systems of the exterior so
Systems Theory all of that so this is
kind of like a ontological compass you
could look at that's sort of an
elaboration and continuation of a lot of
philosophical work and a lot of
spiritual work synthesizing together
that's just sort of the compass part of
it and from there there's lots of maps
of that the Wilbur's set in particular
with integral theory has done an
incredible job of like they're kind of
compatibilism for the interior
traditions and meaning systems and the
exterior sort of mechanics right like
bringing that all together
he wrote amazing amazing work many
different things but one of them's even
called the marriage of sense and soul so
that the ethos behind is very much how
do we sort of reconcile the mapping the
whole of actuality in a kind of an outer
what's a you know the inner in the outer
and like all the systems that have
evolved since then the pluralistic you
know what we've learned from
post-modernism with the lower-left and
then the the kind of systems theories
angles on the lower right bringing all
that together and yeah it's created this
really comprehensive framework that you
know has been a vital pillar for the
realm of transpersonal psychology and
like developing that which you know
people are you know continuing the
Jungian work of the collective
unconscious and then also like metal
lifetime work with near-death
experiences and planned medicine
journeys and all that kind of stuff it's
that's where it's sort of expanding
right now yes so it's kind of growing
out of Wilbur's sort of kind of the
baseline I think framework for the time
the plant medicines are really coming up
big in terms of people experiencing the
subtle realms in ways that we're not as
accessible before except for these
traditions that held those lines so that
that will side of it is opening up in
terms of like the experiencing of all of
this which is a little
different than the orthodoxies of the
religions like the religions were
mapping the similar territories but
people what they were mediating them
also people weren't really able to
access experiencing it for themselves
huge shift there and the parallels with
that on the interior alongside these
developments with simulation theory
coming out is like a serious you know
like it's being considered you know in
philosophical but also scientific
circles now you know with Bostrom's
paper and like you know it's getting all
kinds of press out there it's got a
resonance and I think it's gonna
continue to have an efficacy and in that
area which again with the interior
experiencing of the medicines and or
other types of altered states alongside
the exterior correlates of you know
information and blueprints and things
that are coming through all this
together is kind of I think a
continuation of the mapping project of
the trans rational period so the period
after you know kind of post conventional
rationality that is able to include and
transcend as Willers heuristics have
beautifully presented the continuing of
over this process and more detailed
cartography and and it's it kind of
oscillating through these interior
experiences into exterior forms of like
you know literal subordinate software
encoding right like with the internet
and AI and all these things that are
evolving that we're working on now it's
like the layer of that within the game
yeah yeah that's really taking off so we
have the we have the internal mapping
that has being been done through the
spiritual practices religious practices
now this the psychedelic de monetization
and Renaissance and then we have a this
it's a simultaneous spiritual awakening
on the inner workings at the same time
as we're having an explosive exponential
technology Renaissance were these
theories of super intelligence
artificial general intelligence the
passing of the torch from biological to
non-biological intelligence and
embedding consciousness in that so that
there can be kids in Disneyland as
you know as experience qualia as as it
goes so you know so tell us about that
trajectory with this torch pass to the
super intelligence because simulation
Theory what the matrix is done and the
popularization of this culture has made
it much easier for us to to believe in
what is this passing of the toy your app
exactly and that's part of the some of
the fruit of the narrative paradigm and
and then again all these things that are
kind of coming up in science and
philosophy at this point I mean one
thing that's interesting about it is you
could look at a potential disembodied
trajectory for this where it's
simulations birthing simulations on that
may actually be what some are navigating
as the dimensional stack coming down
vibrating down into 3d this is getting a
little abstract but like some are
experiencing that and there's higher
dimensional and we're working with all
kinds of brilliant minds Cleese been
doing some really incredible work and
and others Garrett Lisi and then there's
others that I've been working with in
emerging tech leveraging higher
dimensional vector spaces for data
storage and so on and and there's seems
to be some correlation with these things
we seem to be able to be experiencing
higher dimensionality when we when we're
navigating these altered states and then
we obviously have this kind of denser 3d
sort of layer of the game and then we
have the subordinate dimensionality
that's expanding outward through
virtuality within it so it almost looks
like an axis coming down on the
vibration and dimensionality density and
then going the other direction right up
higher and higher not through virtuality
now question is is that we're
experiencing a lot of like collateral
impacts - of a disembodied potential of
a lot of this so there are some that
many of us are drawn to simulation media
these things but we can also see how
some of this stuff has been impacting
our embodied health and well-being yeah
yeah so there's a lot of blowback and I
think very importantly and there's
really amazing people in our network
like Emily Bush who's also involved in
vs. and she there's some that are just
really focused on helping to keep this
this stuff from going into
such a disembodied kind of fracture that
it's colliding with other aspects of our
being so there's a question about
whether this is something that's going
to kind of happen in waves and that like
kind of going back to an idea that we
are quantum computers already and we're
you know bio wetware quantum computers
and that maybe we have this kind of we
can talk about this again later but this
window of time where the subordinate
simulation has been evolving in front of
us and getting to this point where now
it's rolling out into 3d with what we're
doing with versus in the spatial web and
may evolve from silicon into other forms
and substrates what's going on with DNA
computing and quantum and all this it
could be that there's this transhumanist
you know kind of window where rather
than going you know there's a
disembodied period maybe but that we're
also supposed to be kind of like sort of
pulling it back into embodiment we have
a period of time we can work on it sort
of outside of ourselves in a way and
that maybe in time it's all going to
evolve back into one sort of stream
we're gonna computing is gonna go denser
and denser and denser down to you know
DNA which were already doing George
jurors have been you know encoding and
decoding just in and out of DNA totally
aside from the you know biological you
know the life functions of it just as
like a piece of like hard drive you know
yeah you know using it like a hard drive
or memory so that with all the synthetic
biology stuff he's been tracking and
like the whole transhumanists you know
movement and all that kind of stuff it
could be that we have a window you have
time to kind of I don't know hopefully
refine yes our values our development
all the things that we want to kind of
continue on through like a large macro
generational torch handing yeah yeah
yeah so we we've we have this this this
period now where where you you know
you're you're calling it this you know
this is a window this transhumanist
window this the the passing of the torch
what codes are we gonna embed in the
super intelligence which codes will
prevail across the countries across the
governments across the companies who
substrates
we'll be the ones that people enter in
on all these interesting questions and
how do we embed the how do we have
discourse around which values to embed
these are all very pressing questions
and one of the things that vs. is doing
which I think you know you should
explain is you know we we never really
had a identification system for humans
when this evolutionary experiment first
started it was kind of like grunt the
name and name was kind of the thing but
you wouldn't really leave go too far
away then now it's you know you give
these digital social profiles that
anyone can find from around the world
you have an identifier to your name with
your like social number your social
credit all these types of things and so
now with what vs. is doing it's it's
it's taking us into this transhumanist
period with with architecting the infer
the infrastructure yeah the web
infrastructure IOT sensors
identification tags open data flows so
yeah teach us about how you get
efficient well yeah yeah so so far maybe
I could just show you jump back to like
the continuing continuum of simulation
like the yeah well the subordinate
simulation and how its evolved into yeah
yes and then we'll go from that to it's
going yeah versus them and into the
simulation yeah yeah so you know we can
look back at the kind of birth of the
symbolic order once we started encoding
data you know there's oral traditions
and so on but when we started kind of
you know scrolling on the cave walls and
the the paintings and so on we started
externalizing data as the first you know
like external data storage formats and
then you know so art has been kind of
the consortin tin uum of the mediums of
art subordinate within so like the game
with if this is a 3d game then like we
have this encoding stream of information
that's been stored externally in this
evolution of mediums is continuous
simulation I think bread liners talked a
lot about this as well he's another
amazing visionary in the space of
virtuality so there's been all these
mediums of art music and so on and then
you know they kind of build up and then
obviously when they get to you know
photography then it then you had this
grand synthesis with motion pictures and
me
where we get this other huge paradigm
integration that you know combines
multiple senses multiple lenses of you
know audio-video together in you know
there's a certain kind of like almost
magical properties of what happens with
those syncing in terms of immersion so
this whole process is kind of its it
seems driven by like deepened immersion
and one respect to the point that you
can then get all these you know kind of
primate bodies that are hypnotized
staring at walls for hours on end at
this 2d projection right so this
dimensional projection things is sort of
definitely something alongside certain
kinds of fractal patterns and scale and
variance and distribution and so on but
the dimensional projection is a huge
part of this thing that's always kind of
been there right yeah so that whole kind
of thing is evolving within and then
it's gotten to a point where it's the
mimetics evolving over time alongside
our genetics into the external so that's
the external objective data encoding
side of the mimetic yeah the mimic layer
so all these layers whether it be like
biosphere noosphere this is other stuff
will retain incredible mapping with but
these and these are very macro
categories of course like physio sphere
biosphere in new sphere they they have
interior and exterior correlates right
so like there's all the stuff that's
going on in our subjective mimetics the
things that are being processed in our
minds individually collectively etc and
then this is the externalization the the
data storage layer of that yes is this
whole continuum of virtual simulated
mediums right and so that both like
comes from this layer it's it's like it
there's the 3d gross layer that
information moves through into that
subordinate simulation whether it be a
painting photograph movie you know media
game so that whole development right
there is we're like filtering into what
ends up there and then it also feeds
back very powerfully obviously Airy
powers exactly it's a closed-loop
feedback it's like a it's a it's a
projection of our limbic system is the
interwebs and then
as musk said and that's a straight yeah
feedback that's super powerful so the
things that make it through the gateways
of wherever things come from right so
that in some circles there there aren't
a whole lot of great explanations other
than what have been coming through the
religions and the plant medicines as to
where ideas come from yeah information
is coming from those are some of the
best that we've got and this is an
attempt to sort of reintegrate them and
synthesize them from when you know
thousands of years ago when they didn't
have anything other than like books to
then create a metaphor of Akashic
libraries or something like that you
know books were the only medium of the
time or something you could say that
could be you know articulated now we
have games and Internet's and you know
movie all these things and so whatever
that thing is of the time we can then
access and now it's at a point where
it's actually creating actual simulation
within the simulation right where it's
kind of you know gaining some autonomy
and we continuously see that coming with
AI this this window that we have with
that but basically you know getting to
this point where the the subordinate
continuum has evolved now through that
media layer into this Internet of
basically an information piping system
still lens through 2d screens right no
three trees and now with verses we are
rolling through that into the spatial
internet is a full stack of emerging
technologies that is it's digitizing
space not just media and documents but
like space itself and then within that
infrastructure the things that AI and
other in other areas of emerging
technologies are going to be able to do
with that framework or at a whole nother
level than if they're in like a walled
garden in a lab or something like it's
it's it's Co evolving with us it's a
physical space exactly yeah it's no
longer just an appendage that is we keep
in our pockets and access just a couple
times a day
it's now a we'll look at the trend of
emerged then full-fledged yeah exactly
so the immersive qualities of having it
be layered in our space whether a our VR
you know I mean just there's that level
of
further immersive power inches closer to
simulation theory it does it is I mean
it is what it is it's the layer within
the layer and also the responsibility to
kind of avoid the Orwellian cautionary
tale correct so this is another area
that people are very concerned about
there's all these gateways and windows
of concern and so like who's actually
having the hard discussions with the
brain computer interface people on the
planet with all the 5g infrastructure
that's going into place on the plan to
longitudinal health effects that these
things may have that how do we get a
global discourse going on about
synthetic biology play in this as well
as just the mimetics that are gonna be
who controls the substrate of where the
mimetics
go directly into right us and you know
right jackass and yeah when and you know
with that flow of mimetics is who owns
that how do we engage with with that on
on a civil discourse on a global
discourse about what is considered best
on progress towards that that simulation
so the Stewart we don't we don't have a
civil dialogue so eat drink and be
married well okay so there are many
people many theories about who is
controlling these things and you know
kind of studying cultural theory culture
crafting I think Adam Curtis is a great
place to kind of dig into some of that
stuff about you know century the self
and Bearnaise and a lot of these kinds
of you know strategies and systems of
control that have been working through
prior forms of media entertainment pop
culture it's of course all programming
systems and so on right now there's a
lot of people that that almost feel like
a kind of victim hood I guess you could
say against the power structures that
seem to be very powerfully or dominated
kind of dominating the
the filtration process that would you
know makes it out there however the
internet I really love it was inspired
by what Klee was saying on the show
about how there's been thresholds of
kind of openness that have been crossed
where you can't really we've just gone
past certain certain you know censorship
thresholds it seems with the amount of
freedom of information that seems to be
available on the Internet to whatever
degree you may you know yeah subscribe
to that so I think there's something
that definitely happened there that
there's more access as increasing access
and so there's other layers of emerging
tech that have been coming through that
seemed to be along those lines that have
to do with the centralization and yes
empowerment and decision aviation and I
think there's a lot of really beautiful
help and potential going on too
if you combine versus how you're
building out that spatial web
infrastructure that if you combine that
with decentralization we're at its
finest yes if it's combined
decentralization at its finest that its
most pinnacle possibility we're in good
hands yeah yeah because then we're
having really strong consensus protocols
around decision making together yeah and
then we can really figure out what codes
we want to embed in the super
intelligence so okay so now let's let's
venture into the super intelligence more
so so interesting is the 20th
anniversary of the matrix we're having
this conversation and all the technology
should just again we're talking about
brain computer interfaces
indistinguishable virtual reality isn't
about you always create things and
wherever these things are gonna be in 20
years it's gonna be a lot closer to
making more people more aware of the
possibility of simulation theory being
true right so we're catalyzing an
awakening of simulation theory at the
same time as the excellent
Mattox so so so so and this gets kind of
crazy because on on as a as a
civilization gets to this point of
singularity that to get to this point of
creating their own simulations and
betting consciousness in them and
watching what the valves and and and
that has felt experience qualia than how
is this already not just another version
of that all the way down yeah so yes so
so the unpack this more for us so what
would specific what arity simulations
all well yeah okay so that so the the
simulations all the way down thing is
interesting in that again it could be
this you know there's a concern about
the disembodied trajectory but maybe
that is how this works there's also like
Klee and and and others have been kind
of meant I'd love to have a mention this
on your show as well and as we're doing
an upcoming panel on descendant theory
which has come through a few different
friends and our network stance tell
maker and Liana sananda over with maps
and RAC myself T Ferry Lisa were we're
gonna be doing a panel on this with
Kelly at the transpersonal hall it's a
psych Association conference coming up
so the idea about this is it kind of
interesting you've got a no variant of
sim theory where it's almost like this
iterative circular process that you know
whether it be a big thing that you know
kind of explodes things out into
differentiation and then they sort of
spin up in development yeah yeah to a
point where then they start to iterate
within like we're already iterating
right now within this one so you kind of
get that fractal self-similar recursion
thing going on you know the simulation
whether the simulation that we're
talking about right now and that is the
spiral dynamics of a whole civilization
evolving Big Bang happens civilization
evolved skits the super intelligence
creates another potential Big Bang that
and then and then again we have this
sort of potential window where it's like
ordinated in front of us where we're
kind of interfacing with it again
bi-directional feedback and so on
obviously but it's in an externalized
form right now right imagining that we
are also already quantum computers
potentially like AI you know in this in
this cycle but like basically we we
would be sort of working on this layer
within you could say and we have a
period of time to grow and develop in
terms of what makes it through into
these gateways at what the AI you know
ends up being sort of programmed with or
what kind of what kind of codes you know
I think we're moving to this period from
where we've we've been tracking like
genetic code like this physio sphere
codes as genetic codes obviously
probably far more going on and not then
we've been aware of of course and then
mimetics
is another layer of coding but then in
the virtual now we're also like getting
this parallel where we're you know
potentially gonna have more Universal
codes underneath things in the digital
space kind of universal code substrates
and so on and also we're now in science
seeing that there may be such a thing
like the opening quote in physics that
there's quantum level codes that
underwrite this so again layer within a
layer and a window to kind of be working
on the subordinate layer while it's
mirroring and we're discovering more
about the physical you know what's under
underlying quantum in the physical
informational essentially and are we
gonna be able to integrate this in a way
like the descendant theory is sort of an
idea that this is a cyclical iterative
process that like as this process
develops and grows it spins up and
through into some kind of singularity
which then back simulates this whole
process in iterations and that there's
emergent properties that like maybe one
theory on the goal for this is that it's
a filtering of both building on what's
come before we can see this in
evolutionary design patterns and
structures now like evolutionary theory
developmental theory and a lot of what
Wilbur and others have been tracking and
an integral theory trying to integrate
that but we see this you know like
stabilizing force of areas of
development
kind of you know Sentra P almost
emergent emergence theory complexity
theory looking at it what emerges as
development occurs versus like the
entropy effective dispersive kind of
chaotic so there's like entropy versus
extra P or s entropy right and as
development occurs there seemed to be
emergent properties that are not found
on lower levels and that is sort of a
kind of general heuristic of what's
being sculpted by this you know inner
outer reflexivity you know the process
of all this densifying of information
and and novelty is a part of that
there's like this kind of novelty factor
but like novelty has to be harnessed by
those entropy extra P forces into
functional fit like evolutionary fit so
that creates a stabilizing structure
that can be built upon and then there's
emergent properties that seem to be
layering through that process as it as
information becomes more dense and more
complex in each phase and so now that's
what's happening again with this virtual
phase this this kind of subordinate
phase and what makes it through these
gateways is a selection process that
that in descendant theory is what also
then back simulates the whole thing it
could be like big bangs two
singularities over and over again or an
expanding collapse of you know in a kind
of eternal universe of you know the 3d
realm different ways with that so so
crucial to make sure that what is being
embedded into the super intelligence
into the singularity simulation is what
we want as if fact you know comes again
that we wanted to be embedded with the
best codes and another thing that I I'm
finding
super fascinating about this is that if
if we can awaken more people to the
possibility of of seeing things from a
big history perspective of Big Bang two
planets and stars to evolution on rocks
to intelligence evolving on those raw
and then to that intelligence passing
off the torch to non-biological super
intelligence then that cyclical process
is super fascinating awakening awareness
expanding and I think it's a very
imaginative the abstract the amount of
abstract thought that needs to an
imagination that needs to go into what
that big history timelines actually like
is very important I think for all
children that are born into the world to
at least be aware of and they can figure
out how much they want to dive into it
or not but just that little bit it
catalyzes a tremendous amount of
Awakening and gratitude to to life yeah
yeah and I think the religions were
stewarding that you know in the kind of
pre rational phase and there's been this
sort of you know turf war conflict as
Wilbur's tracked this stuff so
beautifully between the kind of pre
rational stages and each other and then
eventually the rational in postmodern I
think that the the one of the great
gifts of this this this paradigm that
the Wachowski is kind of in tandem with
Wilbur transmitted was and is the the
potential to integrate these things in a
way that updates the values and the
meaning and and all the kind of the sort
of you know the stewardship of
consciousness and humanity that that yes
it was being sort of there's a bit of a
competition amongst religions and so on
but then there's these Gnostic cores and
you know you can look at like Campbell's
work and watts and many of these other
luminaries that also contribute to I
think interval theory in powerful ways
that that beautiful stewardship can now
be kind of compatibly integrated with
all that we've been mapping through the
scientific verifies verifiability truth
filtering that's required for the
efficacy of what we've been been able to
model and predict and like again that
that whole nature of science in itself
it's a simulation function in itself the
brain is a simulation machine like we're
seeing that kind of
yeah self-similarity all over the place
in terms of what the nature of
simulation really is yeah these are and
and to also address that whether it's
biological and non-biological as it
continues to develop it it could become
biological again and that we could as
this process unfolds with the virtuality
it's like it could be this period where
again it's sort of like disembodied a
bit but it couldn't it couldn't you
could sort of synthesize and unify back
into embodiment the more that we crack
the codes down into the genetic and you
know quantum substrates and so on
informational and underlying everything
the more that it could be that our
computing systems evolved down into the
biological they are DNA's the densest
storage medium that we're aware of right
so like we could end up as we're
developing this or as this is developing
itself in many ways it's going to
continue to grow this sort of Metaverse
you know virtual sphere or whatever it
could be that it evolves back into kind
of some symbiotic that could be part of
this iteration process is that it it
maintains a biological basis but may may
be highly advanced by the spins of what
can occur through the disembodied
aspects of it as well I mean we can look
at right now like just the computational
power of machine computers and machines
so far it's it's very very fast but like
simple processes right like it's like
calculators right they can like out-out
compute almost any human but it's it's a
very like isolated domain of computation
whereas we are far more general and you
know this is what the whole generally I
kind of you know thing is it's
biomimicry in a lot of ways but it's
also going to evolve us beyond what we
are so I think it's a tandem kind of
oscillated rhythm really dance as it
goes back to security or whatever it's
going yeah the the solution to what of
what people think is the favorite
favorite paradox is
could potentially be that civilizations
when they read when they reach the super
intelligence threshold just go in word
that's been something yeah rather than
the outward across the cosmos trying to
like talk yeah there ones there just go
inward and Risa me late and that begs
the question as to whether so if it goes
a disembodied trajectory worth you know
things emanating let's say when we're
navigating the the medicines or altered
states of dreams collective unconscious
all that we're somewhere in this kind of
higher dimensional stack that's
emanating down into 3d and vibration and
that this is a you know projection now
the other way that's gonna continue to
go into higher disembodied
dimensionality and that there's going to
be intelligences in that ecosystem
that's another way that the circularity
could be operating is that now it just
evolves out into higher dimensions of
this virtual aspect of you know this
kind of subordinate continuum if you
will but then that also can advance all
the way back up to potentially
simulating which circles back down into
the 3d thanks that's another another
ways that could go totally disembodied
you know yeah so when when we when we
find ourselves born into this playground
that is called Earth and we start
absorbing stimuli analyzing our
environment trying to get the best codes
which one of the things that's so
important is to really apply this treto
principle to all that is what is the
twenty percent of information that you
have to parse for and find that's going
to give you 80 percent of the knowledge
of reality and and how can we find those
codes and make those the clearest codes
for P proceeds that are born into the
world so they can understand those codes
it's a major principle of what well we
care about and another another aspect to
that is that you're constantly tweaking
on our own development to level up for
what we care about you find meaning and
purpose align yourself with it and then
you're leveling up you're gonna
experience hard obstacles adversities
and that's the grit and perseverance
that gets you through knowing that you
that is your meaning of
purpose and so aligning these things of
finding these best codes continuing to
level up is kind of this this game
aspect all right you just hit on a sweet
spot I think and it has to do with
another area of I think fruit from this
trance panshin of trance rationality to
include the simulation paradigm in an
actual like an expanded cartography
model like taking going beyond the inner
the current integral Theory maps into
this kind of meta simulation integral
Theory cartography so this is what's so
important to have been able to include
the interior what was being stewarded by
these pre rational religious or
religious philosophical you know that
the traditions that have been stewarding
the interior being able to make sure
that that so that's what you know the
meaning carrying right the stewardship
of meaning what is all the data without
the meaning of our subjective you know
the qualia to the quanta so I think this
is an opportunity for us to reframe all
of that interior tea into something that
can be more accessible and modernized
and begin to help instruct the
refinement you're talking about see the
roots the refinement of codes right that
goes back to this kind of general
metaphysical principle I think that goes
way beyond just physics the way that
we've been tracking you know that the
principles of entropy and exstrophy the
developmental emergence you know
complexity theory all these kinds of
things I think are actually metaphysical
principles that you know we're seeing in
that physios for your layer we can also
see them to play in the biosphere the
new the new sphere like we can see these
friction flow entropy exstrophy kinds of
you know governing dynamics and I think
I think that that kind of stuff is all
all those principles are sort of
sculpting this feedback between interior
and exterior and and this paradigm has
potential for being able to to
synthesize it again right to really
unite the
fruits of what has been carried by the
traditions and what is now being so
powerfully and dominant domineering Li
sort of mapped and through modernity
industrialization and so on I think this
is one of them I mean like the the
integration codes are kind of like
master heuristic for the harmonization
and coherence of humanity at this time
and then also the you know what's what's
moving through us I love how you said
that it's there's a process of sculpting
that's occurring sculpting yeah it's so
beautifully illustrated that way that
that as the earth has been doing these
countless orbits around the star that
there has been a process of sculpting
from the single cell to multi cell to
animal to human culture development
sculpting and development it's been
orbiting the Suns been orbiting it's
just been in the Milky Way it's just
been insane to see the sculpting
occurring and now when you find us here
it's up to us to embed the best codes in
these final days of sculpting and prior
to the new simulations yes and so it's
become if not the most important thing
to do to have this conversation to think
about it like how do we want to sculpt
civilizations code deployments yeah to
the super intelligent yes and if you
look at the history of civilization you
can look at the competing ideologies as
software I mean just look at it all it's
a big video game yeah this part of the
power of how we can be learning their
own software the u.s. is running their
own soft ideology a software yeah if you
just start looking at the new sphere as
a software system software engineering
just translate everything into that
these kind of terms so looking at these
competitions of both you know belief
systems
you know belief is very closely tied to
ideology ideology is kind of like a just
like a a roll out of a system and
from an ethos and a belief right so
these we have all these different kinds
of competing belief systems that
ideology Springs from an ideology is
like the mobilization platform for it
civilizational operating systems such as
governance systems national interests
and you know all kinds of nits obviously
evolved into the corporate you know kind
of corporate nation states that are
transnational and that are now sort of
still very much influencing ideology I
mean again as it emanates down into the
field of action for most people being
mobilized by these things ideologies the
governing kind of software and then
media is a huge you know kind of one of
the probably dominant dissemination
forums for all these things again Adam
curt is so fantastic so much of his work
is tracking all these different
ideological threads and very much
looking at it as software so a lot of
software's runaway software there's if
you if you take a look at the amount of
humans that are currently using YouTube
as their video platform that those two
billion humans will potentially become
four billion humans using a single
monopoly business substrate for video
and there is Vimeo and there are some
decentralized and options that are
coming up but it's become a runaway
market share and that is ver this
becomes very interesting because we're
talking about what mimetics what code is
being embedded how do you have someone
that just starts up their video platform
try and compete with a video platform
that already has two billion plus people
using it the way that encode the way
that so the way that this can be
leveraged is the way that you get
something like uber so in emerging
technologies there's different waves
just we're talking about emergent like
evolutionary development and you know
biology or you know any any other sphere
but looking at it here in terms of
emerging tech you have emergent
properties that were not present in a
prior wave
whether infrastructure software etc so
before we had this third wave of mobile
gps's and app stores and all these
things you didn't have the sort of
substrate layer for there to be
something like an uber but or Netflix or
whatever right so like once once you get
these infrastructure layers that's how a
Netflix can unseat a blockbuster yes if
you ride that wave right if you're able
to ride that wave interesting there's
gonna be new innovations that could
obsolete bold that can take out that can
well I mean it at least compete it
doesn't necessarily have to take it out
but that this is a this is part of these
gateways in Windows we're talking about
where there's opportunities and if we
have some kind of hope that we're not
just inevitably on an orwellian
trajectory maybe we've threaded this
thing in a certain way or it has been
threaded or designed itself in a certain
way to require there to be puzzle pieces
that have to come through these gateways
so that it doesn't destabilize there
might that's a very kind of almost you
know kind of whoo-whoo or religious
sense of intelligent design behind this
thing but like you could also you know D
personify it with it being just an
iterative process and of some kind or
whatever that's improving itself and we
find that there is the need for
stabilization in order for things to
continue to occur and and the need for
competition for the code to constantly
be stressed and updated with what's been
definitely better yes yes so there are
certain things like whether it be
principles of decentralization or you
know other areas of emerging technology
where we have these kind of new windows
that are coming I mean we still have
people that are finding ways to leverage
you know prior ways but you know this is
the kind of stuff that we're very
excited about with the spatial web with
versus with with many of the different
companies were working with and in the
emerging tech space right now is being
able to yeah kind of help steward the
process a bit with a bit more
democratization of the ideas that can
come in and write that yes yes one of
the best wait one of the best ways to
update the code that we're gonna embed
into superintelligence is to make it
make it more frictionless for ideas for
mimetics to to compete with one another
in the marketplace
you know that way we can figure out what
it what is actually best across like
that consensus and so those we're gonna
we're gonna be working on ways for there
to be just as our system has been able
to very interestingly you know there's
some ways that we got to give some
serious credit to like the quality of
life improvement in many ways you know
comparing now to many years ago so
however much we might get wrapped up in
like control schemes and you know the
sort of monopolization of dominant
domination of you know areas of our
media or something like this we we also
have an incredible quality of life
improvement as this developmental
process has occurred and some of this
rests on economic factors in
gamification and so on and we can we can
harness these principles alongside
democratization and and greater access
and create incentives structures and and
really harness you know beautiful
expansions of economics like
tokenization and token Amin you know
game of fiying toka nama customs that
you know it what what we're talking
about underneath all of the mechanics of
how this works is like being able to get
different kinds of value internalized
Indore yeah in our economy we're dealing
with so many externalize Asians like
externalities of you know not just
climate impact but of the interior yeah
that is being mined right so whether we
have extractive mining going on with our
Planetary Resources that is backfiring
you know the impacts of it are
backfiring and we're seeing the
destabilization in those areas we're
seeing the same thing with collateral
impacts of the attention mining of
consciousness the interior so this is
only amplifying the more immersive this
gets and we have an opportunity to
leverage a lot of these kind of emerging
blueprints to to harmonize these things
I mean that's that's really I think a
lot of lot of the the goal here is you
know some people even get triggered by
this evolving virtuality because they
see the impacts of it it's like you know
people seeing how technology seems to be
a driving force that is both kind of in
acting the environment and our interior
consciousness those that are very
focused on embodiment and health and the
physical 3d which I greatly appreciate I
mean we need those voices to be in all
these rooms and I'm so grateful to
people like Jamie Wales and others that
are you know kind of tugging are kind of
you know maintaining the stability and
harmony on these areas because it's true
they are in their excesses and
polarizations they are they are
impacting other areas of our being and
our in our planet and so on so colors on
a color wheel in terms of our role in
the in the game so orange does a certain
action blue does certain action red
yellow they all do certain action some
is just engaging on a one-on-one level
making an impact on a butterfly affect
one person some is these moonshot 8
billion person impact ideas and all the
spectrum in between yeah and and just
this principle of harmonizing and really
including the heart and the the the
amazing systems that have already arisen
in their design yes and including all of
this stuff and and and and layering and
integrating and having it all work
together and serve like the whole system
bottom-up the whole thing rather than
being you know we've been impacted by
this phase where computation has had us
leaning over and a you know crazy
ergonomics and you know staring at
screens and all that well the spatial
web we I mean we've got this really
incredible opportunity with with what
we're doing with the infrastructure is
the spatial web AR AR holds a lot of
potential for the the whole new
integrated approach to what we
experience computing to be now we've got
to get out of this like you know we're
working on how to continue to serve and
meet the system where it's at with
however we have this extracted mining
imperative that's going on that's
constantly you know mine our attention
mining our you know it's it's really
sucking consciousness up and and
impacting the heck out of it and so
we're we're really working on how to
there are some incredible blueprints
coming through for how to balance like
both catering to those levels while
while stable I you know and some sort of
like a stabilizing
because they were kind of more
fundamental but then also yeah like like
just harmonizing our relationship to to
the whole system basically so the whole
system of all that is yeah yeah and in
one of the most powerful tactics to do
that is a process of a meditation of
inward reflection of self practice and
self work and and and and that's got to
be internalized into the external model
yeah I think that's where like we have
to have the embodied practice we have to
have that whole side that is kind of you
know subjective instead of extracted
mining it's it's sort of investing and
growing again this is a suggestive sign
but then that has to be internalized
into our economic models and centering
game applied to incentive fire right
then you get these whole systems where
you know you got to give some credit to
these you know Facebook's and Google's
and so on with the way that they're
really integrating mindfulness into
their daily their good you know yoga and
this their you know for all the impacts
that we see the casino style you know
just on Harris kind of critique of it's
true but there are also ways that that
people are in these even in these
systems that are they're seeing the
value of growing growing us up in a
healthier way and so it's the clothes
are percolating they're moving around
yeah they're being updated and and over
time and it's up to us to be able to
determine which ones we want to write
and deploy and put into the marketplace
and have people vote on them and this is
this is a very exciting time you know
our questions that we usually ask on the
show have been pretty much answered by
you already like we asked are we alone
in the cosmos and if we're in a
simulation that's the topic of this show
there's there's probably important to
you know hear your thoughts a bit you
you started telling us a bit about this
like densifying well one one thing I
could offer yeah if it's okay would be a
little bit of autobiographical
information as to how I arrived at some
of this stuff yeah well 15 years of
simulation to screen is that's a huge
part of
of this because this gave you a really
abstract way of realizing that you can
do visual effects that give people to
consume emetics at unprecedented rates
of awareness expansion that's a big one
but yeah give us your give us that I
mean I want a biographical yeah I mean
with a little how much time do we have
yeah a little bit yeah give us some so I
mean I kind of started off as an artist
originally and my grandfather worked at
Hughes Aircraft doing moon missions and
he's a rocket scientist and retired
early and kind of started tutoring me
with computers from a very young age I
was tearing apart programming and so
this kind of art and tech side kind of
co-developed and then there's a great
simulation spectacle of cinema was just
this you know huge you know draw for me
constantly so all these things came
together again in this field of visual
effects and that just kind of you know
that became sort of the the main pursuit
for quite a long time which was focusing
on the full spectrum from art through
the sciences and all the technical sides
and having to kind of learn supervise
all the different angles of all of it
kind of as a generalist and supervisor
and time's producer in the business side
as well so it was a big ingestion period
of how to simulate anything and learning
about how all its works to simulate the
screen yeah and so I was a bit like
almost even kind of out of balance in
that phase in terms of my interior I was
very focused on that outer you know kind
of recursive magic which is really you
know isn't magic and and then in time
just on the personal side for me I think
the interior and the print is sort of
when we're talking about those meaning
systems I was always studying philosophy
and psychology and religion all these
things were always just almost
compulsive obsession obsessive
compulsive fascinations and I was always
studying them but I wasn't in deep
practice and it took a lot of what I
call the shadow teachers the illnesses
traumas and fears to kind of force my
force me out of hibernation and you know
in the matrix you
yeah into into the but work with the
plant medicines and so then that you
know breaks open this whole other realm
of navigation through first-person
experience which I think is hugely
important yes yes in a massive and I
just want to give some credit and like
deep bow to all the traditions that have
been carrying out this work into those
that have been trying to help you know
maps and all these other organizations
I'm so grateful to be working with and
like Tibetan Buddhist meditation from
all this all this tradition those that
are carrying these that are carrying the
boughs of years and I look at this form
exactly and it's and that is all a
master epigenetic teacher to process
absolutely ages yeah so now I have you
know I've always studied them but now
I'm in a whole other area of kind of
practice and again the comp the
subjective computation of what has to go
through embodiment and to then I think
really make it and through that
filtration system through all the layers
of meaning and you know the kind of
computation that is what we are embodied
and to have that you know healing and
growth that I've experienced in my own
life from a lot of these other kinds of
impacts of areas of the matrix that you
know we all we all navigate that is a
reharmonization of my own trajectory
that then filters through into this
other work that we're doing and I feel
like the democratization of that is also
a really important imperative yeah at
this time and so just wanted to kind of
do a deep out to all those working in
these areas and yeah huge deep out of
that and also to you because this is you
you're giving us your autobiography and
it's really explains how you got to
where you are today quite well it's like
that that the blend of those stimuli
gets you to yeah where you're at right
now and and you bow to you two verses
and to what is going on right now with
the awakening towards the codes and what
we're embedding into superintelligence
for round two on the on the
would exist beyond the 3d reality the
higher dimensional layers of the game
yeah yeah give us a little taste at that
and then we'll cover it on the insect
well again I think some of that goes
back to the transpersonal realms and
collective unconscious you know those
were the the lineages that that we just
talked about that the religions were
holding and carrying and many others are
also experiencing all kinds of things in
this sort of supernatural area you could
say that I think we'll be given a bit
more again as we translate these things
from either pre rational or hyper
dimensional you know into the kind of
more hyper dimensional technological
kind of game lens right like if we're
looking at it like as a bit of a video
game and we can see the efficacious
nature of that and it's showing itself
you know through our sciences and what
can be verified as as actually
reflecting the fabric of reality and
when in way the way that this that this
game is architected and constructed in
design etc that the illumination through
these medicine experiences maybe that's
another way to look at it is there's
many different modalities and the plant
medicines can be one of the most
powerful there are many others but the
empty antigens I think are a very
powerful way to access in the right
containers and the right you know
contacts and I think I think that
gateway is a huge eye-opener for people
and again it's necessary it's it's part
of the shift there's the exterior
paradigm of you know these things like
integral theory and simulation theories
being these these outer exterior mapping
systems and paradigms that that we can
work with them and frame but we need to
experience them like this is part of one
of the things that has happened through
you know periods of extreme orthodoxy
and like the political nature of
religions and how they became these very
political empires and so on is they
mediation centralization and mediation
to take someone else's word for
something it has become you know
something that I think like you know
those that are now in this phase that
are you know extreme vocal critics of
those kinds of heuristics of the pre
rational phases like folks like Sam
Harris and others they're really you
know continuing to hammer away at those
aspects of the orthodoxy of the pre
rational religions that anything should
be kind of taken on faith or that there
should be anything that that truth
claims that are that are not directly
observable and this is where the
medicines really open that up for a lot
of people to be able to navigate and I I
look forward to seeing more of those
very illuminated Minds being able to
access these realms and and report back
yes yes this whatever is happening
beyond the 3d reality is a very exciting
conversation to be able to unpack on a
on a future conversation together as
well as as well as you as you gave us a
little hint at the what are the uses of
psychedelics in this process of
understanding what is beyond the 3d what
are the codes that we want to understand
about what exists beyond 3d what are we
gonna embed into super intelligence so
so much good stuff and in the first time
that we were able to sit down together
on the show and and discuss you did an
incredible job of helping me filter way
too much information yeah I feel down to
the fact we we spend out of you we spent
two hours synthesizing what was like a
couple hundred words into just like 25
to 30 and then the bullet points that
helped us be able to break this down
into phase 1 phase 2 round 1 round 2
round 3 etc potentially bringing on
other guests to be unpacking this this
simulation theory and all of the good
stuff that that came along with it
Ryan thanks a lot for coming on to the
show we usually ask at least the at
least the question that you haven't
answered is what's the most beautiful
thing in the world most beautiful thing
the world
the all-seeing eye so the subjective eye
the eye within every one of us that is
all one eye mm-hmm so none you notice
the head I put the eye yeah so that
witness interesting you had the witness
of the eye the self but also the witness
of the collective of all which is with
looking out within every eye i yeah is
the yeah very beautiful and all the you
know phantasmagoric novelty and
immersion beauty that'd be holds is also
an inseparable but i would go all the
way into the eye you know the great
witness observer i love it I'm very
excited for our continued conversations
the shows right thanks so much for
having me thank you for all the good
work you're doing thank you thank you
yes yes and thanks everyone for tuning
in we greatly appreciate you tuning in
we would love to hear your thoughts in
the comments below let us know what you
thought about this episode let us know
what you think about Ryan's work you can
check out all those links below to
Ryan's work also go and build the future
everyone manifest your dreams into the
world support the artists and
entrepreneurs that you believe in and
support simulation our links are below
as well who you shout out to Ron Vargas
our producer and director for producing
this episode and we love you very much
and we will see you soon peace